je vous en parlais dans les titres il
avait fui chez les violences djihadistes
au nord ouest du nigeria plus de 4000
nigérian réfugié au niger voisin sont de
retour chez eux retour encouragée par
les autorités locales malgré
l'insécurité et des services quasi
inexistant dans la région à niamey les
précisions de notre correspondant à un
rôle de girard
plus de 500 familles nigérianes ont
quitté le niger ces derniers mois pour
regagner leur région d'origine suite à
l'appel du gouverneur de l'état de borno
frontalier du niger à lui souhaite que
ces populations retourne de leur côté de
la frontière comme dans le reste de
l'état la ville de madame fattori a
accueilli environ un mois des candidats
au retour et même si depuis aucune
attaque d'envergure n'a eu lieu dans la
ville les risques restent très élevés
boko haram et l'état islamique en
afrique de l'ouest continuent de
contrôler des territoires voisins de la
ville ce retour des populations
nigériennes au nigeria eh bien il était
censé s'opérer dans le cadre d'un accord
tripartite entre le niger le nigeria et
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
il n'en est rien puisque ce retour a
effectivement déjà commencé hors de tout
cadre légal et cet accord lui n'a pas
encore été mis en place ça peut
contribuer à des retours qui seront pas
pérenne au bout du compte c'est ça le
problème donc des gens sont susceptibles
de revenir à nouveau au niger ce n'est
pas une bonne chose parce qu'on a
cependant on encourage l'espèce de deux
systèmes ou de dynamique de mouvement
pendulaire et c'est parce qu'on sait pas
ce qu'on veut il est mieux que réfugiés
on attende que les conditions soient là
et qu'on le fasse dans un cas où
justement si finalement accordé et
ce qui parle qui va te permettre de
donner une pérennité à ses retours ça
que les gens rentrent et une fois qu'ils
rentrent ils sont iront dans des
conditions qui de sûreté de dignité et
il ya une assistance qui va redonner il
ya il ya des conditions de sécurité qui
va permettre de retourner à leurs
activités ce niveau-là de l'activité
agricole
car l'objectif affiché de cette
initiative du nigeria c'est d'inciter
les populations expatriées de force mais
aussi les déplacés internes à retourner
travailler dans leurs champs al'approche
de la saison des pluies une initiative
est une manoeuvre pour le moins risqué
depuis 2009 et l'insurrection djihadiste
dans le nord-est du nigeria quarante
mille personnes ont perdu la vie et plus
de deux millions de personnes ont été
forcées à se déplacer hors de la zone